When it comes to the idle
modes in Marshmallow,
I've been saying that
developers don't need to worry
and probably don't need
to change any code either.
But you do need
to test your app.
I'm Joanna Smith,
and by now, you
should know that you can't
escape the testing beast.
Some quick background.
There is nothing
worse for a user
than trying to take a
picture of their dog
being cute only to see that
their battery is at 6%,
and then turning on the
camera kills their phone.
Protecting the battery is
why we created an idle mode
that the system can place your
app in if it hasn't been active
in a while.
And while this may sound
scary, the best advice
I have for you as a
developer is to do nothing,
because App Standby is smart.
It won't happen to the apps
that the user interacts with,
or that have activities
and services running
in the foreground, or
that have notifications
pending in the tray.
App Standby is designed to
restrict background syncs
and jobs for applications
that the user isn't
interested in right now.
So when your app
is being used, it
doesn't need to
worry about this.
And when it isn't,
it shouldn't actually
notice that it's idle, which is
why my advice is to do nothing,
except test your app.
There-- there is that.
Testing how well your app
recovers from an idle mode
is critical to understanding
what your users might see.
So you need to be certain that
any expected notifications are
generated properly, that
downstream messages trigger
the correct response
immediately for high priority
or delayed for normal, and that
delayed messages and syncs are
processed cleanly both in
the daily maintenance window
and after your app is
released from idle mode.
To help you, we created
a new ADB service
that will let you toggle
in and out of App Standby.
So you need a device or an
emulator running Marshmallow,
and then you need to open
your app and leave it running.
And then to force your
app into App Standby,
you first need to
instruct the device
not to pull any power from
the cable connecting it
to your computer,
because being plugged in
means we aren't worried
about battery anymore.
Then you set inactive
true or false
to toggle into or
out of App Standby.
And get inactive will let
you check the current state.
By toggling the status,
you'll know what to expect,
and you can observe whether
your app is behaving properly.
Theoretically, there
should be no surprises
since all of the
background work that
doesn't happen when idle should
run as soon as the idle mode is
released, and nothing is lost.
And any foreground
work means you
aren't going into idle
mode in the first place.
But if you notice something
funny while testing,
you can modify your approach.
GCM messages marked
with a High Priority
tag will reach your app
even through App Standby,
so that you can react to
important information coming
from your server.
And wake locks and alarms are
honored in this idle mode.
So if you need to react to
a particular time, you can.
But for most apps, there should
be very little work involved,
which means that this time, all
you need is to test your code
and then take a nap in
order to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]